hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
weltweite gibt es eine torte ich weiß
wenn ich genau auf der maur hat sich die
gewünscht hatte ich glaub ich hab
einfach irgendwann gesagt ich mache eine
tiramisu torte ich mag tiere mich so als
dass er sehr gerne und als torte finde
ich glaube ich noch mal einen tick
leckerer vor allem deshalb optisch
hübsch aus denn man kann schöne stücke
schneiden und das ganz besondere an
dieser torte sind die selbstgemachten
löffelbiskuits laden das für mich zu
zeigen ich natürlich gleich wieder
funktionieren und im prinzip also das
hätte jetzt vielleicht ganz kompliziert
an ist aber wirklich ganz einfach denn
man macht jetzt nur einen teig man muss
das sowieso für eine tiramisu einen
whisky teig herstellen um einen bizkit
boden zu backen
und dann macht man einfach ein bisschen
mehr teig und kann eben noch
löffelbiskuits spritzen und ich finde
die sie dann so richtig selbst gemacht
aus also nicht wie so eine gekaufte
torte sondern wie eine richtige
ich finde es viel schöner als willi will
s kaufen ja es ist alles so so lina und
sieht man dass handarbeit prinz und
zuallererst werde ich jetzt die
löffelbiskuits und den läuft und den
biskuit teig herstellen und zeigt euch
da vorne kurz die zutaten für den
biskuit teig brauche ich 240 gramm
eiweiß das sind acht stück eine prise
salz 120 gramm zucker 160 gramm eigelb
das sind auch etwa acht bis neun stück
60 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
190 gramm mehl und später etwa 60 bis 70
gramm futter zu kommen
ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal das eiweiß
steif schlagen und zwar gebe ich dann
eine prise salz mit dazu dann wird
nämlich die altersstruktur einfach etwas
schneller zerstört
sobald das eiweiß steif in stuttgart ein
jetzt kommt der zucker noch mehr dazu
und zwar sorgt er dafür dass ist eiweiß
später nicht so flott als ich kann dann
später diesen eischnee besser mit den
restlichen zutaten verbinden das jetzt
noch kurz ein rück- und an so etwa eine
minute weiter schlagen
kann ich hier die schüssel kurz
austauschen
deswegen arbeite ich auch immer gern mit
zwei schlüsseln und muss auch echt
wichtig dass man immer zwei schüsseln
für die küchenmaschine hat dann muss man
nämlich nicht um füllen
da kommt jetzt direkt in die schüssel
rein dann der restliche zucker und
direkt auch etwas vanille extrakt und
ihr könnt jetzt auch an der stelle zum
beispiel etwas abgeriebene
zitronenschale mit rein geben oder
andere an aromen dann schmecken die
löffel bist mit eben auch richtig gut so
und das wird jetzt so etwa 45 minuten
richtig weiß cremig gerührt
so sollte die masse aussehen also
richtig schön locker leicht und weiß
schon jetzt gebe ich das mehl mit dazu
normalerweise muss man das mehl immer
sieben aber dass dieses ganz feine
melisch also dieses mädel vom globus
immer nur wieder sind auch nicht geben
das klingt nämlich nicht sagt es ganz
kurz unterhalten und das mache ich jetzt
in mehreren schritten
jetzt kann ich auch direkt den eischnee
unterheben das mache ich jetzt auch in
so zwei bis drei portionen sieht man
hier auch ganz gut wie sich das sofort
verbindet und es kommt eben dadurch dass
ich jetzt nicht nur eis schnee
aufgeschlagen habe sondern eben auch
zucker mit dem schnee haben
und jetzt will ich den teig in einen
spritzbeutel mit loch thüle und so habe
ich da vorne so eine ganz große lotto
mit ehrlich millimetern durchmesser
falls sie jetzt aber keine spritzbeutel
habt und keine lokale könnt ihr auch
einen gefrierbeutel nehmen und vorne
einfach eine spitze abschneiden
jetzt habe ich vier bereits zwei back
papierbögen vorbereitet und zwar habe
ich auf dem unteren bogen habe ich mir
so striche vorgezeichnet und zwar haben
die hier so einen abstand von sieben
zentimeter
dann habe ich 3 cm zwischen platz
gelassen und dann eben noch mal sieben
zentimeter
das habe ich natürlich auf der rückseite
und spritzt das ganze gepäck hier auf
die vorderseite nicht alle jetzt hier
bemalen muss legt er das zweite
obendrauf
und zwar hilft mir das jetzt so ein
bisschen als schablone dass sich die
löffel bist wird jetzt alle gleichmäßig
spritzen kann
natürlich könnt ihr die löffel bis wird
auch fertig benutzen als ihr müsst ihr
nicht unbedingt für die torte selber
machen
aber der vorteil ist einfach der wenn
man schneidigen löffel isst wird nimmt
dann werden damals eier aus bodenhaltung
zum beispiel benutzt oder sogar
käfighaltung und hier könnt ihr eben bio
oder freilandeier benutzen
also wie gesagt spritze die jetzt sieben
zentimeter lang und immer dazwischen so
ein bisschen platz lassen die gegen ein
kleines bisschen auf
ich habe jetzt etwa 100 schlöffel
biscuits gespritzt und die restliche
politische sank die restliche biscuit
masse die würde jetzt in einem teig habe
und zwar habe ich dann auf 26 cm
eingestellt und es wird dann später
einfach der biss mit boden
die backöfen habe ich jetzt übrigens
auch schon auf 200 grad ober unterhitze
vorgeheizt vorsichtig verteilt werden
befürchten sie löffelbiskuits und den
biss wie take back muss ich ja noch mit
puderzucker bestreuen und zwar deswegen
das im ofen jetzt auch schöne farbe
bekommen also der zucker karamellisiert
dann nämlich kurz vor ende und dann
bekommt ihr eine richtig tolle farbe
den biss gezeigt hier muss man natürlich
auch mit etwas puderzucker bestreuen
jetzt werden die löffelbiskuits im
vorgeheizten ofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze gebacken und zwar für etwa
fünf bis sechs minuten
ich stelle jetzt auch fünf minuten und
die sechste minute stetig fort im ofen
und schaue sie mir an denn die werden am
ende ziemlich schnell braun also dann
bist du wirklich aufpassen und beim
backen mache ich das jetzt also es geht
jetzt auch die mittlere schiene und dann
schließlich den backofen nicht ganz
sondern klein personen dies kein
holzlöffel aufnehmen telefon dafür ja
auch verständlich dass hier so einer
kann nämlich die feuchtigkeit entweichen
und die löffel bis wird werden auch
richtig knusprig und so packe ich jetzt
alle bleche und backt dann auch den biss
gezeigt er brauche aber so etwa zehn
minuten
die tortenböden abgekühlt und ich werde
jetzt direkt schon mal die füllung
zubereiten und später werde ich die
löffelbiskuits auch mit einer kaffee
trinken trinken und dafür bereite ich
jetzt erst mal den kaffee dann nehme ich
jetzt im café bohn und marlies erst noch
selber
und jetzt brauche ich 300 milliliter
starken kaffee oder espresso
der kaffee sitzt abgekühlt und ich
brauche natürlich noch ein paar zutaten
mehr
ich mache jetzt eine therapie so krämer
ich hab jetzt darauf geachtet dass ich
dir jetzt ohne hohes am 8 normalerweise
wenn ich tiramisu mache mache ich das
immer ganz gerne mit ganz frischen ruhm
aber bei der torte wollte ich jetzt
einfach weglassen und hab da jetzt war
auch eine mascarpone creme aber die ist
dann mit quark und mit sahne stadt mit
und die wird dann auch etwas schneller
fest und man muss auf jeden fall nicht
aufpassen dass man die torte noch am
gleichen tag verzehrt das heißt ich kann
sie noch am nächsten und am übernächsten
tag noch essen für die creme brauche ich
500 gramm mascarpone 400 gramm
schlagsahne 250 gramm magerquark 150 g
zucker und etwas seiner fahrt und für
die kaffeetrinker habe ich hier den
kaffee den ich schon abgekühlt haben 300
milliliter und da brauche ich noch 50
milliliter entweder man will sirup oder
mandel likör mandl die körper jetzt zum
beispiel amaretto und dann gibt es eben
noch in mandel sirup so wie hier ein
mantel sirup und einmal amaretto sirup
und das ist dann beides alkoholfrei den
teilchen abgekühlten löse jetzt erstmal
aus der torten form heraus geht am
besten mit seinem taschenmesser und mit
einem tollen wetter kann ich den boden
wegnehmen und direkt auf eine
tortenplatte setzt jetzt darauf einen
bug rahmen essen rum
jetzt kann ich erstmal die grill
zubereiten nämlich zuerst die mascarpone
und die kommt direkt in eine
rührschüssel
und damit die sich jetzt gleich gut mit
der sahne verbindet muss ich zuerst mal
ein bisschen verrühren und dafür
natürlich vorher den stecker einstecken
sobald sie etwas verrührt ist
vom direkten saal mit rein
mir kommt auch direkt der quark mit rein
und bevor ich dann weiter röhre kommt
noch das saunabad pulver und sogar
und beim salat mache ich das immer so
dann nämlich immer pro 100 gramm masse
einen teelöffel das heißt wenn ich jetzt
500 gramm acht monaten hat mach ich
bin's teelöffel rein und dann auf die
400 gramm da noch markiert hier dafür
als immer pro 100 gramm asse ein theater
dann einfach nur kurz streit schlage
als nächstes kann ich jetzt den mantel
sirup mit dem café vermischen
es gibt dem ganzen noch mal richtig
tolles aroma jetzt kann ich auch direkt
schon den biskuit boden damit trinken
comdirect ein drittel der creme auf den
tortenboden und die streiche ich jetzt
schön glatt es geht am besten immer mit
seiner teig karte
so jetzt kann ich dir lasse biscuits
direkt wegnehmen und die lassen sich am
besten lösen wenn sie schon kalt sind
also wirklich die auf dem backpapier
erkalten lassen dann kann man sie gut
ablösen und die schönsten legt er jetzt
am besten direkt weg die komplette
später um den rand herum wird auch ich
die löffel bis jetzt wirklich nur ganz
kurz in die kaffeetrinker ein und setzte
dann direkt als schicht auf die torte
jetzt kommt das zweite drittel der creme
direkt auf den löffelbiskuits und die
streiche ich dann auch das und da kommt
dann noch mal eine schicht löffel bis
mit drauf
und jetzt kann noch das restliche
drittel der creme direkt auf die torte
und die streiche ich dann auch schön
glatt und alles was ihr jetzt übrig habt
an löffelbiskuits brauchen wir natürlich
später noch für die dekoration
aber wenn ihr auch nicht alle verwendet
ihr könnt ihr dann auch einfach in einer
luftdichten dose aufbewahren und die
bleiben dann auch schön knusprig muss es
halt gemacht
und jetzt denke ich die torte direkt ab
und stellt sie für mindestens zwei
stunden in den kühlschrank besser
natürlich drei oder vier stunden dann
ist nämlich richtig schön kalt und dann
kann ich sie auch direkt fertigstellen
die torte ist abgekühlt und jetzt kann
ich den torten rahmen lösen und die
samira darf mir gleich helfen die torte
fertig zu dekorieren
so jetzt schreiben wir etwas kakaopulver
auf die torte drauf ist in bewegung man
so ein bisschen
jetzt können wir machen das zusammen
jetzt leben wir an den rand die
löffelbiskuits aber damit die oben muss
ein bisschen ab stehen und damit es dran
kleben einfacher ist schneide ich unten
jetzt ein bisschen was weg guck mal ob
es von der höhe her passt
jetzt kann die torte direkt
angeschnitten werden
natürlich fragte wahrscheinlich wie
schnell man so eine torte an entscheidet
einfach zwischen diesen löffelbiskuits
durch das muss irgendwann mal die mitte
finden buch hat ein kleines oder großes
natürlich sagen ein großes stück aber
jetzt haben wir gleich so viele gäste da
macht jemand kleines stück so ungefähr
deal an sie sind größeren schon sein
jetzt geht nicht entweder muss jetzt so
oder noch eine reihe weiterer
innovationen auf jeden fall sieht es so
ziemlich auch so bis festausschuss auch
richtig gespannt was eine coole idee
gewesen wäre wenn ein paar hasen liste
oben drauf gehalten war ja tiramisu und
haselnuss eigentlich richtig nach
aussage ihrer mission man ja nie so
gesehen
ja und ich finde im sommer kann man da
auf jeden fall oben drauf zum beispiel
noch also zurzeit frische erdbeeren
draufsetzen
alles prima gespannt ich weiß nicht wie
du immer der torten ist also eigentlich
nicht mal so ein stück von oben nach
unten muss am vegas am schluss immer
mehr ins fernsehen kommt nicht mit
deinem profil künsten egal wie toll es
schmeckt echt zu retten war ich hab den
boden noch nicht deswegen jetzt probiert
da hat er die ganze zeit die creme
allein probiert jetzt probiert den boden
ganz 11 dann soll man jetzt fragen
bestimmt viele ob man zum beispiel den
kaffee austauschen kann
dazu lassen bringen der schmeckt den
cafés nicht zu heftig raus weil noch
diesen man dass die roboter mandl likör
mit dabei hat und ich finde es gleich
denn das ganze so richtig gut aussehen
lassen absolut mit definitiv also ich
sags mal hier richtig
sieht man jetzt ganz gut auch
geschichten da unten diesen biss gezeigt
dann die weißen mascarpone creme
schichten und zwischendrin gesetz
gemachten löffelbiskuits lieber ein
rezept was ihr unbedingt ausprobieren
sollte und das rezept gibt es zum
nachlesen auf sally blog.de ich wünsche
euch jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und ich bin wirklich schon
gespannt auf eure selbst gemachten
löffelbiskuits ohne auf eure selbst
gemachter tiramisu trotte ich bin doch
nur bis bzw
zum beispiel kann aha sind sachlich 2011
genau
also viel spaß am nach wacken bis zum
nächsten mal